let's go to rich Hammond the Rams beat
writer for the Orange County Register
now rich if you are a Rams fan who for
some reason couldn't watch a game last
night how would you describe the Super
Bowl to them confusing you didn't if you
if that was the only Rams game you had
watched all season you you'd be very
confused as to why people were talking
about them the way that they had all
season met that did not look anything
like the team that I'd watched all year
certainly not on offense and just some
of the mistakes that were made some of
the decisions that were made just did
not look like the Rams to me so if I was
a Rams fan who missed that game I think
I'd probably be grateful rich when you
get back home to LA you know that the
fall-off in the game will happen where
do you think the strongest fallout
negativity will be by Rams fans and
maybe the media Shaun McVeigh jarred
golf both other probably McVeigh I mean
I think from what I'm seeing with what
I'm hearing the biggest question is you
know what was going on with Todd Gurley
and I mean I think you have to start
with everybody says well was he hurt you
know maybe they're lying about the
injury well all I can tell you is for
the past month and a half since he
returned from that injury they said he's
healthy he's ready to go he's practicing
he's playing he's going to be a big part
of the game plan I mean these were
things that we heard on a daily basis
practically and then you get to the
Super Bowl and he has 10 carries and and
I think that's going to be the lingering
question or the lingering kind of sting
for fans coming out of that game is what
happened I mean it's a game where you
know you say ok you're going to be
criticized yeah I think he will be but I
think you can look at that one and say
well he just tastes a really good
defense in a really good game plan and
they executed that to a tee I mean that
was a perfect game plan and perfect
execution so I don't put too much of
that on Jared he's a 24 year old
quarterback he made some mistakes but I
do look at the fact that they just not
did not even really try to get that run
game going until parts of the second
half and I've been thinking about it
since the end of the game and and I
still really can't reconcile it you know
another unusual thing about the game was
I we barely saw Defensive Player of the
Year errand
and you know there were a few games
against really good teams where Donald
was quiet what did we learn about how to
sort of slow down Aaron Donald in last
night's game right I mean they're
double-teaming him they're trying to do
a lot of different stuff just to slow
him down I mean I I still see him
getting in the backfield a little bit
yeah you didn't get any sacks and you
didn't get any sacks against the Saints
either so I mean if you look at that you
can say well you know maybe didn't have
quite the impact but I don't know
whether that tells the whole story
because I mean he's he's filling up to
guys sometimes even three guys if
somebody has to come over and chip him
after he breaks through but it did opens
up some space for a guy like Dante
Fowler who I thought was pretty well
coming off the outside I didn't I didn't
necessarily know I mean I've only
watched it once I'd have to go back and
look at the tape but I don't necessarily
know that they got a lot of pressure out
of Hsu and how strong they were coming
up the middle I thought that was going
to have to be a pretty big emphasis but
yeah and in terms of if you're comparing
it side by side that some of the other
games that that Aaron has played where
he's putting up two or three sacks
certainly is it's not as flashy but I
mean that guy is having to you know
fight through about 600 and 700 pounds
of offensive lineman on pretty much
every play rich Hammond Orange County
Register Rams writer joining us I told
you at the before the season that if I
told you in August the Rams are gonna be
in the Super Bowl and they're gonna be
tied going into the fourth quarter 3:3
with the Patriots you'd have said what
surprised I mean I thought I thought
they'd be there and I wonder if Lord I'd
be surprised about is he told me the
score was three to nothing or whatever
it was at that point that would be that
would be the part that I'd be surprised
about but you know to that point I I
think they were pretty comfortable
because I got the defensive game that
they exactly wanted I mean you talked
about or certainly talking about how the
offense it played in its capabilities
and that's a hundred percent true but I
mean you you look at the most optimistic
projection for that Rams defense coming
into the game and I think this exceeded
it I mean they they fight extraordinary
on defense so if you told me that you
know they're going to come into a game
and
you know they're going to have health
the Patriots the three points going into
the fourth quarter I think every Rams
fan would have taken that but obviously
the game did not go the way that I
thought or those people thought it would
rich what is the biggest challenge the
Rams are facing looking ahead to next
season well they've got some holes to
fill and you know the one that's kind of
grown here over the last couple days it
seems increasingly unclear whether or
not Andrew Whitworth is going to return
I mean he talked about at the start of
the week how he examines things after
every offseason so I you know maybe
we're making a little too much of this
particular game because the Super Bowl
but for him to kind of come out and say
hey you know gosh I haven't really
decided yet
Wow I mean that that's going to be a big
one I mean should he decide that you
know at age 37
after a Super Bowl season that he's
ready to go that that's a tremendous
poll that they would have to fill at
left tackle so I think that's going to
be the first one on the list is is
determining what's going on with him and
then the defense is going to change a
little bit I mean Souza free agent
safety LaMarcus Joyner is a free agent
they've got a couple other holes that
they you know might potentially create
you know if they release a guy for
salary cap reasons so the defense will
change a little bit but but really a lot
of the personnel comes back I think a
lot of the work guys will be you know
Shaun McVeigh sitting in his office
watching a lot of tape and saying you
know what happened to that offense and
it wasn't just that Super Bowl I mean
you can even go back to the Detroit game
so the Chicago game the Philly game a
lot of these late season games excuse me
where that Rams offense just wasn't
quite what it was early in the season
and I think Shawn's gonna have to take a
long look at that and say were there any
trends there was there anything that
kind of popped up over and over in those
games that needs to be addressed because
I guarantee you that the Rams 2019
opponents are going to be looking at
those same games and trying to spot the
same things rich every other team in the
league wanted to hire the next Shawn
McVeigh Zach Taylor's going to the
Bengals probably today if you're a team
sitting out there who just hired a new
offensive guy in the Mikve mold are you
service now that maybe that's not gonna
win a Super Bowl or his McVeigh still
the guy well I I think you have to ask
yourself why did you hire him I mean if
people are just and I think people have
been saying there's at least people who
know the Rams and know McVeigh if you're
just looking for a guy who's sat next to
Sean McVeigh in the office and and you
know picked his brain I don't think
that's the right thing to do and I don't
think that's the case with any coach you
shouldn't do that
I mean a lot of what Sean has
accomplished in Los Angeles's because of
his connections to I mean he he has a
good game plan but he also gets guys to
buy in he explains it extraordinarily
well I mean he's a great teacher of
football not just a guy who draws up
plays on the board a great communicator
a guy who put together a great staff in
hiring Wade Phillips so if the person
that you're hiring you you think checks
off all of those boxes also and and also
worked with John McVeigh and maybe learn
some stuff from him you know football
wise that's fine but but I think there's
a danger in just saying oh you know
we're going to go grab guys just because
they work with Sean McVeigh I don't
think that's the right formula I think
you need to make sure you're hiring an
all-around football coach in terms of
leadership in terms of game planning in
terms of everything rather than just
looking at you know the staff that guy
coached on and how many points that they
scored rich thanks a lot for your time
good luck this offseason hopefully the
Rams will be back buddy thank you all
right guys thank you for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]